[Música]
i
todos tenemos un momento en que la vida
nos marca y yo puedo decir que el
momento fue el 23 de noviembre del 2006
momento en que llegó la discapacidad sin
avisar de una hora para la otra
silenciosa y misteriosa
fue una bacteria que entró por la
columna lesionó e inflamó la médula
a eso
nunca me pregunte por qué
a mí sino para que para que llegó la
discapacidad a mi vida he aquí la
respuesta
en esta etapa de mi vida con 22 años
estudiante madre de un niño de dos años
casada
sufría violencia de género
tenía una vida tóxica
entonces la respuesta que me dio la vida
fue que gracias a que llegó la
discapacidad puede salir de esa vida
y yo le doy gracias a la discapacidad
porque gracias a que llevo la
discapacidad me libero
no fue un proceso fácil
estuve 57 días internada al recibir el
alta
fui a vivir a córdoba con mis padres y
mi hijo
en ese ambiente sano
de amor de comprensión
con mamá y papá pude depurar esa vida
tóxica y dejar atrás
y es así que ahora miro el pasado que
quedó atrás y puedo sonreír
este año que vivía en córdoba me
permitió conocer a muchas personas tanto
profesionales personas con discapacidad
de distintas provincias que iban a hacer
la rehabilitación conmigo familiares de
estas personas entre otras
si bien los kinesiólogos fueron
importantes porque me ayudaron
a salir adelante
a reeducar cuerpo a enseñarme a hacerlos
pasar de la silla de ruedas a la cama de
la silla al auto y viceversa hubo una
persona que marcó mucho mi vida y que es
el que generó que yo hoy esté acá y
pueda disfrutar la vida sobre ruedas se
llama jorge era mi enfermero hoy es un
amigo incondicional
y jorge en una noche de mucho frío me
saco del departamento me dejó en medio
de la rampa del edificio donde yo vivía
y me dijo que mi vida estaba de esa
manera a la mitad y que tenía opciones
volver y quedarme encerrada o bajar y
vivir la vida no sólo por mí sino por
ese niño que en esa época tenía casi
tres años
y que hoy tiene 14 años es el pilar
fundamental de mi vida se llama lautaro
y es mi hijo
no dudé un segundo baje esa rampa y
decidí aprender a volar entre tanta
gente de pie
no les voy a decir que fue fácil el
aceptar
este accesorio
que era todo nuevo entonces
estaba mamá y papá para sostenerme para
no dejarme caer y para que yo pueda
aceptar
sin ningún problema este accesorio que
tenía y que tenía que adecuarlo a mi
vida
en las horas de kinesiología
vivimos muchos momentos
que quedan guardados en el baúl de los
recuerdos
y muchos otros anécdotas una de las
cuales les voy a contar que fue el
momento en el que deje de usar la silla
común la de hospital que yo digo que es
un carromato a la que ven hoy que es que
yo le digo que es un mini cooper claro
la otra es un carro es pesada esta es
liviana es ligera se imaginaran las
tantas caídas que hubieron y que hasta
el día de hoy hay por travesuras de
lautaro
es así que ese año en córdoba
decidí que lautaro necesitaba vivir en
su tierra colorada donde donde nació
y cerca de su familia ya que yo soy muy
familiera entonces decidimos emprender
el viaje a nuestra tierra colorada pero
para eso tenía que estar preparada
entonces los quines me enseñaron
a vestirme me enseñaron a desenvolverme
en esta nueva vida
es así que yo vivo sola con lautaro hago
todas las cosas en mi casa desde poner a
lavar la ropa cocinar con la ropa lavar
el piso y bailar porque bailamos con la
útil
entonces una vez instalados ya acá llegó
la separación
de mi ex que en el 2017 se convirtió en
divorcio
y ahí es como que se cerró ese ciclo
soy y me considero una luchadora de los
derechos de las personas con
discapacidad y en especial de los que no
tienen voz o no tienen fuerza
siempre digo que mi lucha es la lucha de
todos
hoy en día me estoy por recibir de
abogada
tengo una página que se llama hablemos
de discapacidad cosas misiones en donde
subo mucha información para concientizar
e informar sobre la importancia de la
inclusión de las personas con
discapacidad
es así que en marzo de este año unos
chicos de buenos aires se contactaron
conmigo porque a través de un vídeo que
yo hice para el día nacional de las
personas con discapacidad se viralizó y
llegó a manos de estos chicos
andrés que ir él y carmelo martín uchu y
me hablaron sobre una aplicación llamada
access app
me hablaron me comentaron el tema y al
ver cuán
identificada y comprometida con la
discapacidad estoy yo
me nombraron embajadora de esta
aplicación de la provincia de misiones
access up es una aplicación móvil que se
pueden bajar por play store uap store y
reúne información turística en todo lo
que es accesibilidad no sólo de nuestra
provincia sino de todo el país
es fácil de usar es ágil y es totalmente
gratuita
access up también no es sólo para
personas con discapacidad sino que
también tiene información para personas
celíacas
con access app
tenés al alcance de tu mano
lo que antes tenías que estar llamando a
discapacidad que antes quería viajar
tenía que estar llamando a los hoteles a
los restaurantes a los distintos parques
a ver si cumplían o no con la debida
accesibilidad hoy con access app que es
la primera y única app que reúne
información sobre accesibilidad
turística para personas con discapacidad
está al alcance de la mano y con un solo
clic
access up fue distinguida por la cámara
de diputados de la nación de interés
nacional también obtuvimos de interés
provincial por nuestra cámara de
representantes de la provincia de
misiones y la semana que viene se va a
tratar en el consejo para que sea
declarada de interés municipal por
nuestro consejo deliberante de posadas
yo les digo que no vean a la
discapacidad como una tragedia
ni tampoco dejen que la discapacidad
condicione su vida porque en mi caso soy
yo quien condiciona a la discapacidad y
no ella a mí
está en uno elegir
la silla se convierte en un ancla o alas
en nuestra vida y yo elegí que sea alas
para poder luchar por mis sueños e
ideales la discapacidad
no es un impedimento para luchar por los
sueños e ideales de cada uno
así que ese es mi consejo que no se
queden
a esperar que llegue salgan a buscar ese
sueño y esos ideales muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
más